welcome to this 15-minute game playing
both sigh borzoi hmm from the US and his
playing a form okay okay I'll play my my
usual 'if I've the Vienna really know
the four nights hmm yeah this is a
notoriously boring opening ah yeah but
of course what can do that it's not bad
how to inject a bit of life into this
yeah we should be fun as the
overwhelming main line I can go Bishop
c5 this is slightly risky but um okay
playing very quickly not trying to to
really refute my my setup which is
probably not possible but Bishop e3
instead of taking on only success I
think on c6 I think a bit more dangerous
okay let's see this some set up by black
does not look very ambitious but it does
have some very aggressive points and we
m well maybe see some of that in the
game it depends on his setup here I have
fun I have interesting ways to play now
one is Nyjah form which looks as usual
very crude but
it has the double idea GreenEDGE form
and 95 I can also just play moves like
bishop on e6 and wait for one move but
I'm going to do that it's interesting
and if you watch my videos you know that
I have this sort of soft spot for Queen
edge form so always try to get this in
okay Mara this is the real threat Queen
edge form I mean he cannot play a
nothing move it should be two or
anything then Queen edge four wins
outright yeah this is some of course the
the normal reply in in bullitt games I
probably would go age five here this is
really really dangerous if it's not
correct but it's it is dangerous okay 95
of course no use to waste more time yeah
this this has some of course the simple
idea to take on d3 get the bishops but
there's also the possibility to continue
with ya you may be guessed it with the
Queen edge form intending Bishop takes
h3 and this can get really dangerous so
it's um something that white needs to
take into account the bishop on c5 is
some dangerous this is also why why it's
very often place I'm night a form in
this type of pawn structure to get rid
of this Bishop it's even a possibility
here yeah this is this is possible but
not without risk if I go queen edge
phone now he probably must take on me
five I do that anyway no use in
pretending it will play something else
of course one one point is that Bishop
d3 i'm just taking okay he took so now
I've got the bishop pair which is nice
but not decisive of course there are
possibilities though that can quickly
turn them turn this into a big disaster
for white Bishop takes h3 as such a
possibility takes Queen g3 check using
the pen King edge one checking again
kingi one and then I just need a rock on
the G file and end up winning and even a
move like h5 with the idea route h6 g6
is very very close to working maybe it
is working if he plays Queen f3 there's
another trick h5 then is interesting
move threatening Bishop g4
yeah tricky business the question is
what should he do maybe it's still night
a form yeah that's not bad actually okay
I'm interesting now this age five is
threatening Bishop g4 I wonder ever
should do that it's um hmm it's a bit
but playing for tricks but it's it's not
a bad trick if it was my move Bishop g4
is winning straight away hghg with made
on h1 and the Queen has simply simply no
no square to go to as Queen g3 I can
just take because of the pin by the c5
bishop now you can play of course Bishop
c4 now and then Bishop g4 is a bit bit
too strong a medicine ya should maybe I
should shut go f6 but so not not bad
yeah f6 or something else yeah castles
does not really fit into this this whole
plan a completely crazy movers f5 it's
really crazy and we are based on the
fact that EF take Queen takes e4 but
just even c6 hanging so this is
completely completely crazy and okay so
this also means that Bishop g4 is not
not so strong anymore hmm still he has a
hard time to take it ever a crazy a
blundering f7 I must play f6 for us
this is cool I was really thinking about
the next move and wow I was just
thinking about the next move she's like
f6 and then Bishop g4 and I'm just
blundering here wow ok at least I only
have one reply who this this will cost
many rating points he's got 770 they
will man oh wow yeah am i is it a
checkmate already somehow okay well this
crazy Bishop g4 it at least for the
moment it comes the D 1 square oh man
yeah I'm probably not even taking this a
big if he gives us check King zi8 smits
it's winning or whatever white can win
in multiple ways problem well but let's
just let's just wait what is playing
Bishop g4 crazy yeah f6 was i think
really okay i mean it is it has this
idea to play Bishop g4 and rook h6 g6 is
this kind of this kind of stuff the king
is not really a badly placed okay it's
taking more material which is really
greedy rook f am this is at least
attacking you an F too
unless he has some great reply then
maybe I'm still still somehow in the
game I don't want to be to sound too
optimistic here but yeah how does the
protective to relief 91 it is not
protected well this means i have at
least a draw like bishop f2 is at least
the draw a look takes Queen takes King
check- us at least a draw but if I play
rook rook f2 isn't this a winning in
this winning if he does not have really
a check a check on on the 8th ranked as
on-site Baruch f8 with a counter check
the same is with rook do you wonders
look T 2 with a counter check yeah I can
do that it should probably win rook
takes Queen takes check king on the edge
for Queen age 4 as a check made and
threatening look at one double check and
queen have to made I don't really see
why that's lucky very lucky okay I was
basically it was not a mouse slip it was
really a blade a brain slip could've
easily be made on f7 I mean I really
didn't say this is made into me it's a
very lucky game of course I really i
just made the second move for the first
one yeah i have six son I mean could
queen air force the computer move here
not bad but this is what I wanted to do
and it's it's it's really it's a bit
shaky yeah but it's interesting queen
bee three hours I was thinking just to
put it here and then then see what he's
doing with with this idea yeah the
computer is merciless we should be five
what a move are these leads to almost
win for white okay yeah this is very
easy losing the bishop and if i go back
which is of course already not what i
wanted you can play this end then grab
the spawn so this means that Queen d3 is
very strong I mean there are many tricks
you have let's say this one oops yeah
they are there are some tricks but yeah
this means that this is what I really
should do what about equal play maybe
down I have a bad porn structure but the
bishops yeah this is the best way to
play F success it's what I wanted to do
but not good really but this isn't the
stuff to see like playing this with this
idea this means that I probably must do
something else like Bishop pierre-luc da
door so but this is also not good look
at this it's even even this smooth yeah
it's it it's a bit fishy what I played
here probably this is strong really
strong a good term a good shots of
prophylactic move for Bishop g4 but it's
hard to really not easy to play him I
can play a passive move like this but
why tis better go on without question
yeah queena form is much stronger and
this is probably the justification of my
my earlier moves yeah interesting and
lucky at the end let's check just a
briefly here yeah yeah I can take here
of course didn't see that with the total
winner and here yeah rook f2 as a forced
made already gap he has no way to
prevent the mate I briefly thought this
one but Jesus sir check check Justin
checkmate just a different made ok
thanks for watching